[Musique]
en ce
temps-là monsieur le surveillant des
classes
secondaires était un peu
efféminé en ce temps-là je lisais de
grands mots n apparis les
lumières je me faisais
plaisir je me faisais
dormir je m'inventé un monde rempli de
femmes aux cheveux rou
j'ai dit des femmes pas des jeunes
[Musique]
filles cette année-là je n'oublierai
jamais le regard de
vipère que m'avais lancé ce vieux
rat cette année-là j'avais jeté mes yeux
sur la croupe
incendiaire de ma professeur de droit
elle avait mis le feu en moi j'avais
avalé la lumière j'aurais aimé la terre
entière r que des femmes pas des jeunes
filles pauvre de moin monsieur le
surveillant des classes
secondaires passer ses nuits à
m'espionner pauvre de moi du couloir des
secondesordoir des
premières comment les jeune était couché
bien sur le dos les bras croisés sur la
couverture de l'INE des fois qu'on
aurait desciidées pauvre
taré pauvre
[Musique]
chimet c'est pourtant là que pendant des
années j'ai rêvé
d'adultère que je n'ai jamais
consommé et chaque
fois que je tiens dans mes bras une
femme trop fière qui se refuse à me
donner un peu plus que le
nécessaire parce que j'hésite à la
défaire de son carcan de préjugé parce
que je n'ai pas la manière j'ai j'ai
presque envie de lui
confier qu'en ce temps-là j'avais un
surveillant des classes
secondaire mais ça la
ferait rigoler
[Musique]
foreign